we're getting a bus what do you mean
we're getting a bus wow welcome aboard
noodles it's like infinite full noodles
we're building these foam walls we've
got noodles for days we have
300 one of these hold on we only need
about 200 of them we need 180 of them
turns out that i need to cut two inch
pieces
pvc we go in between the two junctures
like this i need 28 on each side
56 for each half wall 112 in each full
wall
why did we not just buy two inch pieces
it's really cheap just to buy 10 footers
the majority of the work here is the
cutting
and fitting and gluing all these pieces
together we're going to randomize the
color
of the noodles to make it interesting
other than that it's very very easy
it kind of looks like a jail for babies
so the wood i'm going to be doing later
this is much more simple
in fortnite there is also there are wood
walls we're doing a foam version
and the wood version putting the fencing
posts down putting the eight vise on top
using the nail gun
to help them stand i put legs on them so
that they can stand on their own so
they'll make a point of contact
in the corners and then we'll have these
foldable legs
on hinges to give it more support on it
so to make it easier for us to maneuver
them and place them when we're on set
next week
today is bus day we're getting a bus
what do you mean we're getting a bus
just out of the goodness of his heart
he's
giving us up who gives people buses
basically this group of like
three or four young 20 year olds
children
yeah not children but yeah you know like
20 years early early 20 year olds were
working at this camp over in new york
and they're all from new zealand or
something
oh so they're working they were working
at this summer camp and now it's the end
of their summer camp so they bought this
bus
to travel the u.s for the final weeks of
summer
pretty cool we have to fly back to new
zealand at the end of this and we don't
know what to do with this bus does
corridor want it
oh and nikolas was like hey did you see
that message we should say yes and check
it out
dude they're going to give us a buck
basically just giving us the bus because
they're like we would rather gift it
than sell it because we'd rather go to a
good cause
or a production that's kind of sweet and
when they expected to show up
within like five minutes yeah what i'm
expecting
this bus to be like 50 jank 50
bus i'm expecting this bus to sit in a
parking space
collect a bunch of cobwebs and dust and
then get towed
or we have to pay to demolish it that's
what i'm expecting the best use of this
bus is to do a short work it's destroyed
that's the best use of this bus
it's hard to move a bus around for
production and production i mean i moved
a u-haul and
two that was for one yeah for one week
like that was a week what are we gonna
do with
it for every other day of the month do
they have a title for it that they're
going to give us or something like i
mean we're going to find out in five
minutes i have my god
let's go see the bus all right i'm gonna
withhold judgment
until i see the bus jake's a bus gas
tank half empty kind of guy i'm a bus
gas tank half
nice to meet you man you drove this
thing across country huh yeah
there it's painted it's painting it's a
red bus
oh wow welcome to the rest of your life
you drove all the way from austin
by yourself yeah well it's just on the
egg and then i had a friend off the
coast
okay okay how many uh kids does this fit
uh kids
don't know how can i go in yeah look
around what's the most amount of
kids that have been in here i have no
idea oh my gosh
this is like the most clean renovated
school bus i've ever been in
there's seat belts this is bringing me
back dude look at this dude
dude this is bringing me this is too
real man my bus ride was really long i
had the longest bus ride of anyone on
the bus i was always the last kid to get
off same
yeah i gotta get out of here hey sam hey
give me your lunchable no shut up come
here
so this is all the places you've been
yeah it's the way we came down the coast
i haven't updated it since austin but
it's good that's okay oh yeah i just had
to do this
welcome aboard
all right oh my gosh this is the loot
crate from fortnite
and it's sort of what we're going for so
the rounded top
use the heat gun to shape the foam it's
crafty foam that looks like wood
building a box out of foam is difficult
out of wood i think it probably is
easier because you know you can cut
everything everything's
nice and rigid i made pink board kind of
a skeleton to
frame everything i only had so many feet
of the metal
and i was running out so nick suggested
using duct tape which up close on that
camera i'm sure you can tell
the color is so close like it's so close
and then with the paint job going all
over it i think it's just gonna
disappear for the most part and it
really helps clean up the edges
yeah and you know i got hinges on there
and it doesn't quite you know
close all the way but whatever and it's
all cartoony i figure if it doesn't
quite match
it kind of goes with that cartoony
themes all right come on everybody
let's get down there and just start
blocking this thing sounds good
i want to see where they are
cool no good connections in it don't
know they're kind of cool
oh yeah these guys came out and i
repaired them yesterday and they came
right back out and
throw again
who designed these who built this i mean
i'm gonna get one done so you can take
it and then work on the rest
okay that'll do i just didn't know if we
had it i knew there was some on the
table in there
uh as i was afraid of in transpo
the breads were not strong enough boards
are coming out so i'm glad i'd screwed
at least one screw into each of them but
we were done so that way they kind of
stayed intact and now i've just made
sure there's two screws
at least in every board so it shouldn't
go anywhere now
when you're moving vehicles there's a
lot of coordination first of all it's a
big huge
piece of machinery it's you need safety
and you need to coordinate you want to
make sure somebody's just
really nearly backing up a truck when
there's a bunch of gear of people
standing behind them there's a lot of
coordination to get the vehicles
in a place where they're going to be
nearby and useful yet
out of the way and not in the shot and
so we're constantly moving vehicles you
want to hopefully find spots where we
can kind of park this
they're hidden by some trees and get
what we need when we need it yeah i'd
say
less vehicles would definitely be ideal
you know we had to kind of split things
up where one car was passengers and one
car was always props and art so it would
be awesome if there was some type of
vehicle that can
kind of do both
lit up all the gear oh yeah
take a look oh man the or the 88
the old 88 model they don't make them
like they used to the problem with short
bus is after this model after 88
they're too long do you have the title
yes you do have the title i do have the
title
i can outfit it with solar panels on the
top with a big battery array to have
like power all your electronics for days
you can jump up on there twist the
handle wait can i get up on the roof
right now
wait i gotta stand on a bus man
how hot is it up there just to make sure
i'm on a bus i'm on a bus
where's the oil this cap where's the oil
filter we're never allowed to open this
now i can i can outfit it with solar
panels on the top with a big battery
array to power all your electronics
we're going to burning man dude did
these people's kids forever bro
you can yell at people in the back dude
welcome to the rest of your life
[Music]
i don't think we can take it i hate to
say it
the reason is not because i don't want a
bus or because i don't have a place to
park it
the reason is because we have to get the
title registration
and insurance and that is a major hassle
it's a super cool bus i'm not sure we
can take it
if we had just a lot and we're like guys
just put it back over the lot i would
blow it up
someday and then i would totally take it
but it could fit in my driveway
i mean there we go if you wanna die you
wanted to jump
on that driver it's like hot potato dude
this is your tiny home dude i gotta call
my wife
yeah there you go yeah and we'll just
hold it
from here man how do you feel about
noodles hitting you in the face
what a loaded question i feel exuberant
that i'm going to be slapped in the face
with noodles
and then once yeah once i'm laying down
just like everything's on me
little billy there's something very
cathartic about destroying your creation
because you're now done with it die my
son
it's been a rough start to be honest but
that's uh it happens sometimes and
that's what we're dealing with so
[Music]
so it's
yep yeah good good you're right good
nick you're
wow
usually day one with cruz is is kind of
that warm up getting the groove day so
once we get in the groove it'll be
rolling and tomorrow there should be
zero hiccups
you